eight seconds to go
Randall on the drive Stripped by Butler
Randall gets it back Bravo puts up a
three
[Applause]
seven tenths of a second remaining
Randall stumbling bumbling after turning
it over previously regain his composure
able to get the ball to go
you must finish the grid of Miss
partisan crowd
and we would say somebody's open pass it
pick it up surrounded by Heat and the
three goes I think they're looking to
make sure his feet were behind the arc
it was very close at least on that
replay let's see maybe get a better look
he's seen his omnipotence the whole
evening with guys just ripped all over
him it's time love looks love looks
looking to float it in pass stolen by
Robinson it's over the Knicks win again
eight in a row as they hold on to beat
the Miami Heat
and the heat were
discombobulated on the inbounds love
didn't seem to be sure to who to get the
ball to